la fin de l'année bien c'est souvent
l'occasion pour plusieurs de faire des
bilans et puis renault manuguerra gagné
journaliste scientifique c'est s'est
donné comme défi tient renault de
choisir les meilleures découvertes
scientifiques très intéressant comme
comme bilan qu'on va faire ensemble ce
matin
c'est un bilan que j'ai trouvé vraiment
le fun à faire parce que il ya eu
beaucoup de découvertes importantes en
2018 mais là dessus en avait plusieurs
même si c'était vraiment fascinante
c'était des choses qui se limitaient
dont l'effet se limite au monde de la
recherche et en a d'autres qui servait
surtout à expliquer certains phénomènes
on n'a qu'à penser à toutes les études
sur le climat qui sont parés au cours
des dernières semaines donc à trois
jours de noël moi aussi je voulais
vraiment faire un top3 des découvertes
qui risque d'avoir un effet vraiment
positif ou de régler des problèmes au
cours des prochaines années
la première pour avoir un impact direct
sur l'environnement oui justement
soucier si un des éléments dont on a
beaucoup parlé en 2018 et encore on
parle d'environnement oui les
changements climatiques mais on a aussi
beaucoup parlé plastique donc une
dizaine on a des dizaines de millions
tonnes qui s'ajoute à nos océans chaque
année et en 2018 on a vu certains et
certaines villes où certaines compagnies
faire des gestes symboliques comme
interdire des sacs de plastique ou
interdire les pailles mais il va
vraiment falloir plus que ce qu'on veut
régler le problème et en avril dernier
il ya des chercheurs qui ont découvert
une molécule qui est capable de dégrader
le plastique donc eux ils étaient en
train d'étudier une bactérie qui se
nourrit de polyéthylène ce c'est un
plastique qui représente 40% de toute la
production annuelle c'est ce qu'on
retrouve dans nos bouteilles en
plastique par exemple
et cette bactérie produit une enzyme qui
est capable de digérer le plastique en
quelques semaines digérer thierry après
ça c'est se laisser ramené à décomposer
totalement organique avec qui vont peu
qu'ils peuvent se décomposer dans la
nature elle le fait en quelques semaines
mais en travaillant dessus
ils l'ont modifié ils ont rendu ils ont
augmenté son efficacité de 20 % ils ont
rendus capables de dégrader d'autres
types de plastiques
donc c'est à l'heure actuelle c'est pas
nous c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
utiliser pour se débarrasser des
milliards de tonnes de plastique dans
l'environnement
mais les chercheurs travaillent là
dessus pour vraiment le trans
transformer cette molécule en outils
pour protéger l'environnement
ce qu'on voudrait faire assez de
l'utiliser à grande échelle à grande
échelle ce sera plus difficile de
l'utiliser comme ce serait plus pour
l'utiliser par exemple dans des centres
de tri ou dans des
ou dans des dépotoirs ou dans des
endroits où il ya une accumulation de
déchets leur larguer de molécules comme
ça dans la nature sauf sursaut va
falloir voir un peu avant de prendre des
décisions seraient certainement aider
dans les centres de tri sur wii
surtout si on veut récupérer plastique
dans les océans puis ensuite on s'en
débarrasse comme ça et sinon en santé
publique l'un des plus gros problème
reste la crise d appuyer reid
on en parlait justement cette semaine
avec l'ontario oha effectivement puis
une seule des chercheurs qui ont trouvé
une molécule qui pourrait aider c'est
pas une solution qui va permettre de
guiers 2 d'aider les personnes qui sont
déjà accros aux opioïdes
mais ça pourrait éviter des d'autres
patients de tomber dépendant de ce
médicament ce médicament là parce que
les options il faut le rappeler c'est
l'anti douleur le plus puissant qu'on
connaisse mais il vient avec un énorme
risque de dépendance donc en septembre
dernier il ya des chercheurs qui
annonçait avoir créé une molécule qui
est 100 fois plus puissante que la
morphine pour ce qui est de d'éviter de
diminuer la douleur mais qui ne vient
avec aucun des effets secondaires des
opioïdes donc aucune accoutumance aucune
dépendance et aucun risque d'arrêt
respiratoire et dans des tests sur des
singles et les animaux ont montré aucun
de ces effets secondaires donc ça
pourrait être molécules qui nous permet
de diminuer la douleur chez les gens
sans risque
là on vient de finir les tests animaux
donc c'est sûr que ça va prendre encore
du temps avant de se retrouver chez les
gens ou sur le marché mais étant donné
l'ampleur de cette crise la baisse ça
reste une très bonne nouvelle et très
attendue des choses c'est certain hélas
pour terminer en médecine
tiens l'histoire qui vous êtes vous le
plus impressionné c'est and will smith
se targue en novembre dernier c'était un
quelque chose de vraiment incroyable à
l'aide d'électrodes implantées dans la
colonne vertébrale
il ya des chercheurs français et suisses
qui ont réussi à redonner à des patients
paraplégiques la capacité de marcher
donc c'est des chercheurs qui ont
implanté des électeurs directement dans
les nerfs de la moelle épinière et en
plus une batterie à l'intérieur de leur
corps et après plusieurs mois de
réadaptation ces patients ne sont pas
ces deux êtres en chaise roulante tout
le temps à être capable de se déplacer
comme on peut le voir ici par eux mêmes
à l'aide à l'aide de marché tout
d'autres ou d'autres appuis
donc c'est électro de l'est qu'elle
fonséca stimule les cellules lasser les
cellules nerveuses
entre la blessure et les jambes comme ça
ça ta main au signal de passer du
cerveau jusqu'aux muscles
et ce qui est vraiment remarquable dans
cette expérience là c'est que après un
certain temps d'utilisation les patients
avaient plus besoin de l'appareil il
pouvait l'éteindre et pouvait marcher
quand même
donc ça veut dire que eu une forme de
guérison de réparation leur moelle
épinière la magie c'est pas de la séance
car c'est presque là en fait c'est
presque de la magie se dirait parce que
les chercheurs eux-mêmes ne savent pas
comment une chose comme ça il posté bis
av juste que c'est ce qu'ils ont vu donc
on pense que le type de blessure que eu
au départ un grand rôle à jouer dans la
capacité de guérir donc ça veut pas dire
que toutes les personnes qui ont eu
c'est que tu utilises tu apparais là
vont avoir un effet aussi spectaculaire
mais donc les chercheurs c'est ce qui
veut dire que les chercheurs concert
quand même que leur technologie c'est un
outil pour aider la réadaptation soit un
outil pour guérir les gens mais pour les
personnes qui comme on a vu à l'écran on
record ont pu recommencer à marcher par
humains baisse savait pas de prix comme
ça change la ville sainte a tout changé
le soleil ils récupèreront jamais la
marche qu'ils avaient à 20 mais juste
elle capable de se tenir debout c'est
magique oui je comprends et on va
pourvoir bilan cette fois ci on va faire
les découvertes de l'année
donc les grandes découvertes toutes
catégories confondues et qu'on peut
s'attendre en 2019 aussi avec la science
merci beaucoup je le souhaite aussi